the controversy doesn't seem to have put
a damper on the mood
primark staff are welcoming irish prime
minister enda kenny
he's here for the opening of a new store
in berlin
so i'm glad to be here with you for the
opening of
your 276th
store worldwide
your 13th store in germany
and your second store here in berlin
primark is a hit across europe
hundreds of customers are waiting
outside
most are teens and young women
we want to save money
expensive clothes when you can get cheap
ones they don't last as long but they
look good
and do they care where the clothes are
made and how
you do end up feeling bad when you're
shopping and you have these people on
your conscience
but other than that
most of the customers here seem to agree
what they care about most is the price
and at primark prices are rock bottom
t-shirts sell for three euros and up
pants and dresses start at 12.
most of the customers are aware that
wages for the people who make the
clothes must be rock bottom too
kaiova helman studies consumer behavior
in germany
is it's not easy to find out where
things are made and under what
conditions
it takes a lot of time
and you have to be pretty knowledgeable
a lot of the information is secret too
so most consumers don't pay all that
much attention to what's happening
behind the scenes
like many other major retailers primark
orders clothes from factories in asia
including ones in bangladesh
bangladesh is one of the world's major
textile producers
workers in the clothing industry here
earn a pittance
about 60 euros a month on average
a year ago a garment factory in dhaka
collapsed killing more than 1100 people
extremely low wages poor safety
conditions and little by way of labor
standards that's also common in georgia
we're on the road with a union official
in batumi a city that's at the center of
the country's textile industry
more than seven thousand people work in
these three garment factories
almost all are women
few are even aware that they're entitled
to certain rights
ilia fedsadza is trying to organize them
to fight back against low wages
he's not allowed on the factory grounds
no one gets in there not even
independent inspectors
i ask the women how much they earn but
they won't tell me
if they had a decent wage they'd tell me
how much they are
only two of the seamstresses are willing
to speak before the camera
they say they can earn up to 150 euros a
month but that's not enough to survive
many earn a lot less than that because
they're paid by the piece
they only calculate the time that the
sewing machine is in operation
we don't get paid for the time we spend
laying out the fabric or for numbering
counting and sorting the finished
garments
we have to work very very fast
that's the only way to earn enough
if you can't do that you get less money
do consumers truly not care about what's
happening behind the scenes
some say they do think about it
like this student who's planning to
spend about 50 euros today
a month's wage for some garment workers
i do know what the conditions are like
of course
and i hope i'll earn good money someday
so i can shop somewhere else
they can try to interrupt the process by
doing their shopping elsewhere
that's a utopian idea but it's certainly
possible
day in and day out we're all capable of
thinking about how we want to consume
but very few people take that step
most consumers are mainly out for a
bargain